hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comte they're going to be
starting a new series on Bobby Fischer
and we're going to take a look at some
of his most memorable games that he's
ever played
obviously Bobby Fischer being one of the
greatest chess player that's ever played
has played some extremely epic matches
and you can learn a lot from his matches
so I thought this would be a great
series to start with and the first game
we're going to be looking at today comes
from his very first u.s. championship it
was back in 1957 at the time he was only
14 years of age and in 1957 he actually
had his second best record ever a few
years later he would actually have a
perfect 11 points but in this one he
ended up winning at the ripe age of 14
the next year he actually went on to
become the youngest Grandmaster of all
time so he's not quite at that level yet
he's still very young but extremely
talented for his age and so in this
championship were going to be looking at
one of his matches is between James
Sherwin at the time a 24 year old player
actually got third in this tournament so
an extremely you know accomplished US
player in his own right and Bobby
Fischer in this match is going to be
playing the white pieces James Irwin is
going to be defending with the black
people Bobby Fischer starts off with
pawn to e4 pawn c5 this is the Sicilian
defense so if you're not familiar I
definitely recommend checking out that
video but continues with Knight f3 pawn
d6 pawn d4 and then after capture the
knight recaptures Knight f6 just
development moves Knight c3 and then
pawn to a6 Black has a lot of different
variations that he could go into he
could try some of the dragon lines and
this particular defense James Sherwin
decided to play the knight Dorf just
this pawn to a6 and this is one of the
most common defenses that you'll see in
top-level play again Bobby Fischer a
huge proponent of this pawn to e4 and so
the Sicilian defense neither variation
is extremely popular for black at high
level Bobby Fischer is going to continue
with Bishop to c4 again development move
trying to control the center of the
board also attacking this pawn here at
a7 sharone's going to respond with pawn
to e6 kind of blocking off getting ready
to you know have this solid pawn chain
right here but want to make sure this
light square bishop isn't do
a whole heck of a lot Bobby Fischer is
going to castle on the kingside and then
black is going to start a little
counter-attack and try to push forward
and put some pressure on this bishop on
c4 the bishop is just going to come back
here to b3 and blacks not done going to
push forward with his pawn here to c3
now Bobby Fischer plays Knight to b1 not
really the more common moves that you'll
see from white under developing your
pieces back here to b1 usually kind of
frowned upon it's more common to see you
know Knight to a4 you know still
somewhat of an active piece you never
want to have your your Knights on the on
the edge here but it's going to be very
easy later for him to get involved into
the game you know move like Knights of
CC 5 after this pawn moves you can
always place you know pawn right here or
pawn here on b4 and have a nice little
outpost but Bobby Fischer plays Knight
to b1 and then the bishops going to come
here to d7 again getting all the pieces
developed into the game Bob fish are
going to play Bishop to e3 getting his
dark square Bishop Bob into the game the
Knights going to come here to c6 and
then Bobby Fischer is going to play pawn
to f3 now black did have the option here
you could have you know played Knight
takes here on e4 which would have been
you know all that bad he decided not to
instead he decided to just play you know
Knight to c6 and then the pawn is going
to come here to f3 and protect this pawn
black responds with Bishop to f7 getting
all of his minor pieces involved into
the game center of the board right here
both of his bishops connected in the
nights over here so that he can castle
on the King side Bobby Fischer's not
going to play pawn to c3 what Bobby
Fischer really wants is he wants this
pawn to recapture so that his knight can
recapture here on c3 this would be best
case scenario for Bobby Fischer that he
can recapture and get his Knight back
involved into the game Neph his pawn to
c3 black actually did respond and he
took with his pawn here on you know c3
he did have different options he could
have played something like pawn to a5
that way you know if the pawn takes here
on b4 and the pawn recaptures this is
opening up this a file for this rook
here it's also really holding down you
know the
square here on c3 again Bobby Fischer
wants to get this night involved to the
game so this is just going to be a thorn
in his side for the time being so again
definitely not the recommended way just
to do exactly what Bobby Fischer wants
you to do but the pawns going to take
right here and then Bobby Fischer first
takes with his night here on c6 then
after the bishop takes on c6 Bobby
Fischer's going to play Knight takes on
c3 again he now has all of his minor
pieces involved into the board he's
controlling the center of the board next
thing he needs to do is get his queen
he's connected his rooks on the back row
and then they can really start to attack
his opponent now black responds with
castling on the King side again King
side safety is always important Bobby
Fischer now plays rook to c1 you want to
get your rooks active squares maybe you
want to get them in open files semi open
files so they can roam around the board
again if you have your rooks that aren't
active you're going to have a huge piece
that's not really doing a whole heck of
a lot in the game so rook to c1 nice
little move the Queen's going to come
over here to b8 nice little active
square putting a lot of pressure on the
Queen side from Bobby Fischer here and
then Bobby Fischer plays Knight to d5
really really aggressive square you
could have you know played Knight to e2
opening up for his rook to come to c6
putting a lot of pressure on that open
file he decides instead to play Knight
to d5 now in the game sherman actually
took with his pawn here on d5 probably
would have made more sense to be
captured with his night here on d5 Bobby
Fischer has a lot of different ways that
he can recapture but at the end of the
day the in solution is Bobby Fischer
doesn't have a super aggressive position
in the actual game the pawn took here on
d5 and then after the rook took on c6
and then the pawns came off the board
this is going to be very aggressive for
Bobby Fischer obviously you can tell
right here that his rook is on the c6
file very aggressive he has both of his
bishops here kind of dominating the
center of the board and the Starks
square bishop for James Sherwin isn't
doing a whole heck of a lot so again
this is the position that you know
Sherwin ended up with probably would
have made more sense if instead he
captured with his night here on d5 from
here black plays Queen to
ooby five you know pretty active square
um you know it could have just played
Knight to e4 but he does get into some
problems with Bishop here to d5 again he
has a discovered attack if he moves his
rook so he decides okay I don't want to
have to deal with that even though I
gain material there so instead he just
decides to play Queen here to b5 and
then the rook swings over to b6 now
again Blackson not the worst shape ever
he's definitely going to need to get his
dark square bishop bobbins of the game
but you know he could play a move like
Queen to d7 here still pretty active
controlling a lot of these light squares
in the center of the board also you know
protecting this pawn here this is going
to be completely okay unfortunately for
black he makes a huge error in the game
and he plays Queen over to e5 again just
not doing a whole heck of a lot for him
and this Bishop can now come to d4 much
better Square for Bobby Fischer here
much active controlling the center of
the board and now blacks just kind of
responding he has his no real gameplan
and Bobby Fischer's just putting all of
his pieces into better positions if you
kind of looked from black right here you
know after the Queen comes over here to
g5 all those pieces are just kind of
protecting each other nothing's really
active there's no real attack that he
has and white all of his pieces are
aimed you know it either center of the
board or at the King set if you look at
all these bishops they're all lined up
right here so Bobby Fischer now plays
Queen to f3 didn't really have to do
this he had other options here he could
have tried something you know like rook
here to b7 you always want to get your
rooks on the seventh rank they can just
add so much pressure to your opponent
you know you're attacking right here on
East 7 you know later on the bishop
could come here to d5 nice little
outpost for him so definitely had this
nice little move that I think you missed
instead he played Queen here to f3
wanted to make sure that he was
protecting this pawn here on e4 from the
night you know coming there and taking
now the Knights going to come over here
to the 7 less-active square for black
you know attacking the knight but it's
not really doing a whole heck of a lot
can sit
the night or that the rook can just come
here to b7 and this is exactly where
Bobby Fischer wants his rook is on the
seventh rate you know putting a lot of
pressure on his opponent
but James Sherwin now brings his knight
here to e5 nice little outpost move
recognizing the Bobby Fischer's probably
not going to exchange you know his
bishop Boff sense you know it's an open
board and bishops tend to do better
especially the later game and in open
game since they just control more of the
board right here so recognizing this
this is going to be a nice little
outpost for black the Queen just comes
back here to eat two nice little safe
move from Bobby Fischer doesn't want to
have to exchange off and considering his
queen is being attacked
he definitely has to move it now
although we talked about the reasons why
Bobby Fischer might not want to get rid
of his bishop it still probably would
have been a decent move for Bobby
Fischer just to take with his bishop
here on e5 after the Queen takes or the
pawn takes if we look at it you know the
pawn takes here on e5 you know Bobby
Fischer still has more aggressive pieces
he has his Bishop and his Queen and his
rook all lined up on this you know f7
square right here also his rook on b7 is
very active so you know although he
brought his Queen back and you know
that's not the worst move ever he still
would have had a very good game if he
took with his Bishop here on e5 but
we've if we come back here after the
knight comes to e5 the Queen's going to
come down at E - and then the bishop
comes to f6 wants to make sure it's
still not being harassed by this rook
here on b7 definitely needs to get it to
a better square and then the Queen's
going to come over here - h1 wants to
make sure since he doesn't have a pawn
here on f2 that later into the game he
doesn't have to deal with you know let's
say this Knight moved and then the
bishop took here on d4 and there would
be a check once to make sure that he
just has is king in a very safe position
now the pawns going to push forward on
a5 if you kind of look at this from
black you know what is your really going
to do these two have some sort of
counter attack yes both sides are even
in material but why it's just way more
aggressive so it needs to find some sort
of counter attack and Ponte for
attacking on the the Queen side is
really all that he has right now White's
now going to play Bishop to d5 and this
is a great move from Bobby Fischer you
always need to be looking out for
outpost for your pieces and this is a
great outpost force Bishop here on d5
not only is it in the center of the
board so he can you know control all the
light squares on the board but also once
this rook move he does have a discovered
attack on the rook here on a1 so good as
you're playing your own games Bobby
Fischer does a great job showing us in
this game particular we'll see more that
later on but all these fundamentals in
chess that he just plays to perfection
now the rooks are going to come over
here to c8 again controlling this long
file as we talked about much better than
just over here on rooked it a also
because of the discovered attack when
the rook moves on b7 being attacked by
the bishop here on d5 definitely wants
to make sure that he moves that rook now
Bobby Fischer is going to bring his
bishop back down to c3 making sure that
this route can't you know come down to
you know c1 since he does have the
protection here from the Queen here on
g5 on c1 so kind of blocking it off
right here on outpost on c3 is not
nearly as a you know impressive or
aggressive as you know here on d5 but it
does block off this rook so it kind of
makes the attack right away from black
somewhat Nolan boy
blacks now I'm going to play pawn to a4
again pushing the pawn it is also being
attacked by the bishop here and c3 so
wants to move it out of the way
and then Bobby Fischer plays rook over
to a7 attacking this pawn here a4 he
does have in my opinion a more
aggressive move they could have played
you know Queen to a6 makes a lot of
sense right here not only putting
pressure on the pawn on a4 but also the
pawn to d6 and the Queen's not really
needed you know this pawns not being you
know attacked anymore by the night and
his rook on on f1 is completely safe
doesn't have to worry too much about it
and since this rooks not going to be
doing any harm this Queen to h6
is a very very strong move from Bobby
Fischer but in the game you played rook
over to 87 which seems logical
you know attacking this this rook on a4
it's going to be really hard for black
to defend this pawn and so black now
plays Knight over here to g4 recognizing
that okay he can't do a whole heck of a
lot but all
opening up the door for a discovered
attack on the bishop here on c3 Bobby
Fischer now plays rook taking on a four
in this position I really feel like he
has to play Bishop here to d2 because
the exchange that we'll see here in a
second it just leaves Bobby Fischer in a
bad spot in this position he's attacking
the Queen here on d5
Black's going to have to respond with
this he can't take a move you know
Bishop here to be to this is going to be
horrible he has to take care of this and
then after the Queen moves you know the
rook can come down here on a four and
take that's going to be completely fun
in the game Bobby Fischer took right
away wasn't really looking for kind of
the in-between move and took with his
rook on a four and then after the bishop
took in the pawn took the rooks going to
come down here to c3 and in this
position both sides are actually equal
black has a very aggressive position
obviously his rook here on c3 it's much
more aggressive than it was here on c8
later on he can swing his rook over to
c8 get those involved into the game
again his queen is eyeing down on the c1
file so you can always play backup if
the rook comes down further so this is
not going to be a terrible position for
black at all and White's really going to
have to find a nice attack to continue
luckily for whites being played by one
of the greatest chess players of all
time even at the age of 14 he just saw
the game so well Bobby Fischer played
the rook takes here on f7 this is just a
really hard move for black to deal with
and he could play something you know
like pawn to h5 which probably the best
move just because it allows if this rook
moves you know the King can come here to
h7 if he needs to starting to attack on
the King side here again really hard
move to find in the game black actually
played rook to c1 giving up any equality
or advantage that black may have had and
what he probably saw is this is going to
be completely fine I'm checking Bobby
Fischer so after the rook comes down you
know there's a discovered attack and the
King's just kind of gum up over here to
h8 and then black is going to be fine
it's going to be in an aggressive
position but you know if the rook comes
here then the queen is going to
recapture on c1 blacks looking really
good right here again he has his rook on
f8 ready to get involved into the game
what he didn't see was a nice little
deflection move from Bobby Fischer and
it's Queen here to f1 and this is huge
because you know if the rook captures
here on f1 then the route can come down
on f1 check because the discovered
attack and then let's say if the Queen
takes here on d5 there's not a whole lot
of options then the rook can take on f8
and then after the king takes then the
pawn takes and this is going to be an
easy game for Bobby Fischer obviously
he's up in material not only from the
major minor piece but he does have this
past pawn right here that he can easily
push forward and it's going to be you
know good game for Bobby Fischer so you
know in that position after the Queen
came here to f1 black decided okay I
can't really exchange pieces I'm gonna
have to figure something else out to do
so instead he plays the pawn here to h5
which seems reasonable again he wants to
it's all too late though but he
recognizes he needs some sort of
counter-attack
unfortunately he now found a nice little
decoy move from Bobby Fischer and it's
Queen takes here on c1 recognizing that
the Queen can't take here on c1 or the
rook can just come here to f1 again it
was nice little decoys you won but after
the decoy was taken and there is a
discovered attack on the king then the
rook can just come over here to see one
in take that that Queen so recognizing
this you know black plays Queen here to
h4 trying to set up the the Queen to h2
here for checkmate recognizing that you
know it's just not going very well Bobby
Fischer just has a huge attack and you
just didn't see that Queen to f1 move
early on Bobby Fischer now takes on at
f8 checking the king and then after the
king comes here to h7 Bobby Fischer
plays pawn to h3 stopping the immediate
threat of you know Queen to h1 checkmate
Queen's gonna come to g3 again just
trying something now just trying to play
this Queen to h2 checkmate
but Bobby Fischer says
not going to allow that I'm just going
to take with my pawn here on g4 and then
after the pawn comes to h4 kind of a
last-ditch effort you know trying to
push something forward to protect this
Queen for the checkmate then the bishop
is going to come here to East 6th
protecting the pawn and from here black
resigns and just said good game this is
what allowed Bobby Fischer to go on and
to win the US Championship so definitely
even at the age of 14 recognizing all
just these tactics in chess so far as
you know getting these discovered
attacks finding these nice little
outpost moves in the stern of the board
finding nice deflections and decoys it
was just really great to see at a huge
stage first u.s. championship that he
really put on you know all the chest
lessons that he really could on his
opponent so hopefully you guys enjoy
this video again we're going to be going
over all the Bobby Fischer's greatest
moments in chess and hopefully you guys
are enjoying this and learning from
these and I'll see you all in the next
video thanks for watching